[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24 en
tranquilidad y con baja participación
fueron realizadas las elecciones
parlamentarias en venezuela 20 millones
de ciudadanos fueron llamados a
participar en unas cuestionadas
elecciones que no cuentan con el
reconocimiento internacional
a los 80 años y víctima de un cáncer de
pulmón falleció el ex presidente de
uruguay tabaré vázquez a quien se
convirtió en el primer mandatario de
izquierda en gobernar ese país
suramericano
la unión europea y el reino unido- hacen
sus últimos esfuerzos para concretar un
acuerdo para la era post el éxito las
partes tienen discrepancias en cuanto al
futuro en la relación londres bruselas
en cuanto a la gobernanza y a los
acuerdos de pesca y las fronteras
muy buenas noches soy santiago lópez
gonzález estamos en vivo aquí en las
noticias de france 24 desde nuestros
estudios en bogotá en colombia a esta
hora avanza el conteo de los votos
después del cierre de las urnas en
venezuela las elecciones parlamentarias
se desarrollaron en total tranquilidad
pero con serios señalamientos de fraude
desde la oposición que estuvieron
ausentes en estos comicios que a su vez
hizo un llamado masivo a la abstención
natalia plaza nos cuenta más en el
siguiente informe
una jornada electoral que según la
oposición es todo menos democrática el
equipo de france 24 en caracas constató
la baja participación durante el día y
es que mientras un pequeño sector
opositor presente en los tarjetones
asegura que un 40 por ciento de los
electores participó durante la mañana el
grueso de la oposición reduce esa cifra
a un 76 % y la interpreta como un
rechazo masivo al gobierno precisamente
los detractores de maduro liderados por
juan guaidó han llamado al boicot y
nosotros le estamos pidiendo y le
estamos solicitando a el mundo entero
que entienda que no solamente hoy hay un
fraude sino que la asamblea nacional a
partir del 5 de enero electa
legítimamente en diciembre del año 2015
tiene que continuar su mandato
institucional y que juan guaidó tiene
que continuar como presidente encargado
y varias naciones entre ellas eeuu y la
unión europea consideran las elecciones
un fraude para que el gobierno retome el
control de la asamblea único poder en
manos de la oposición desde 2015 por
ello el presidente nicolás maduro acusó
a la oposición de haber tramado un plan
para impedir los comicios le hago un
llamado a toda la oposición que abandono
de la ruta extremista que aproveche la
derrota de donald trump para abandonar
la agenda intervencionista de eeuu
que le pidamos en una sola voz el
levantamiento de todas las sanciones al
nuevo gobierno de eeuu joe biden
es que de acuerdo con una encuesta de la
firma datanálisis el 62,2 por ciento de
los venezolanos no respalda ni al
gobierno ni a la oposición porque
independientemente de la situación
política que tenga la gente es un deber
cívico solo señor a uno cuando uno está
en sexto grado moral y luces no tiene
que votar es un deber cívico eso no es
porque yo quiero que es un deber de
acuerdo con el consejo nacional
electoral venezolano cercano al
oficialismo el proceso ha contado con
veeduría internacional y observadores de
una docena de países
y vamos a analizar este tema con la
talla rojas ella es decana de la
facultad de gobierno y relaciones
internacionales de la universidad santo
tomás en la ciudad de bogotá en colombia
con quien vamos a analizar entonces este
tema muy buenas noches natasha gracias
por estar con nosotros aquí en france 24
y que sucederá a partir de ese 5 de
enero cuando asuma esta nueva asamblea
nacional qué va a pasar con la que está
ejerciendo el cargo hasta el momento y
qué va a pasar con juan guaidó que es el
presidente de este organismo legislativo
bueno lo que estamos viendo y los
pronunciamientos incluso anteriores a
las elecciones desde varios países de la
comunidad internacional es el no
reconocimiento de este proceso que se
está llevando hoy en venezuela incluso
anterior aunque se diera cualquier tipo
de resultados sobre la participación
sobre lo que estamos viendo que está
ocurriendo hoy durante todo el día ya
muchísimos países habían dado su y
habían fijado su posición ante el no
reconocimiento esto nos llevaría a
pensar que pese a que este órgano esto
estas personas que fueron seleccionadas
vayan a empezar a ejercer funciones al
lado del régimen a partir del 5 de enero
esa asamblea presidida
cuando basile siendo reconocida por una
buena parte de los países de la
comunidad internacional como ha venido
sucediendo hasta este muerto
natasha muchas gracias por este análisis
para nuestra audiencia aquí en france24
avanzamos con otros temas destacados
falleció a sus 80 años víctimas de
cáncer de pulmón el ex presidente de la
república oriental del uruguay tabaré
vázquez quien fuera el líder del partido
frente amplio vázquez destacado político
en su país era médico oncólogo de
profesión el gobierno decretó allí tres
días de luto nacional y también ordenó
que todas las banderas ondeen a media
asta
previamente karina de almas nuestra
corresponsal en montevideo la capital
uruguaya nos dio más detalles sobre esta
jornada criado en un barrio humilde de
la teja en montevideo se recibió de
médico luego se especializó en oncología
y tuvo una larga trayectoria política
generando grandes logros para el frente
amplio primero con la intendencia de
montevideo la capital
de uruguay en 1989 y luego con dos
presidencias en el 2005 y 2015 rompiendo
la hegemonía de los partidos
tradicionales durante su primer
presidencia debió enfrentar un país con
40% de pobreza así generó políticas de
estado que se mantienen hasta el día de
hoy como mayor acceso a servicios de
salud a internet gratuita para todos los
niños de la educación primaria y también
tecnologías de la información entre
varias otras políticas también a nivel
internacional resurgió su nombre tras
enfrentarse a las tabacaleras
internacionales como philip morris al
prohibir el uso de cigarrillos en
lugares públicos y la publicidad de lo
mismo lo que lleva ya una larga batalla
legal internacional la cual ganó pero no
estuvo exento de polémica por ejemplo
con el veto de la ley
del aborto el cual había sido impulsado
por el propio frente amplio pero que el
veto por razones filosóficas o el
conflicto con el país vecino argentina
tras la instalación de una papelera en
el río uruguay la cual había sido
acusada de supuesta contaminación en
otros temas la unión europea y el reino
unido- hacen los últimos esfuerzos para
concretar un acuerdo post break si
presentan discrepancias en cuanto al
equilibrio en la relación londres
bruselas también en cuanto a la
gobernanza y en los temas de pesca los
jefes negociadores en reanudarán las
conversaciones en bruselas el lunes para
alcanzar puntos en común las partes
tienen hasta el 31 de diciembre de 2020
para llegar a un acuerdo las
restricciones comerciales generan
incertidumbre también en el ex clave
británico de gibraltar cuya economía
depende en gran medida del intercambio
de bienes con españa una facilidad
comercial que podría terminar a partir
de enero del 2021
gibraltar podría estar a punto de
desmoronarse si el break se queda sin
acuerdo los controles fronterizos
podrían interrumpir el flujo de turistas
que mientras están de vacaciones en
españa suelen visitar gibraltar el peñón
recibe 10 millones de visitantes al año
y el turismo es la sangre vital de su
economía
con una frontera cerrada o con una
frontera más estrecha todo lo que la
gente en la frontera tiene que hacer es
tomarse unos 10 o 15 segundos para
comprobar el papeleo de todos y va a
tener una cola de kilómetros así que
esto va a hacer que la gente deje de
visitar gibraltar lo que los residentes
españoles y británicos también han
cruzado la frontera a diario durante
décadas 15.000 residentes de la unión
europea trabajan en gibraltar mientras
que unos 2500 británicos viven en españa
por las viviendas más baratas el
territorio británico no solo depende del
flujo libre de personas también importa
todos sus alimentos
estamos estudiando otras rutas para
abastecer a gibraltar que incluye una
ruta meridional y otras alternativas
para el suministro de fuentes de
mercancías del norte y en particular el
reino unido a la vida cambiará
radicalmente para peor si no hay un
acuerdo y no sólo para el pueblo de
gibraltar
teniendo la destrucción que traería al
break shit los locales votaron por
permanecer en la unión europea en un 96
por ciento pero eso no evitará que estén
sujetos a las mismas restricciones que
el resto del reino unido cuando el
período de transición termine el próximo
31 de diciembre a medianoche y para el
cierre les contamos que una cápsula
japonesa con las primeras muestras del
subsuelo de un asteroide cruzó ya la
atmósfera terrestre antes de aterrizar
de manera exitosa en una zona remota de
australia de esta manera completó una
misión para obtener indicios sobre el
origen del sistema solar y también de la
vida en nuestro planeta la sonda
espacial hayabusa 2 libero una pequeña
cápsula que regreso a nuestro planeta
con estas muestras tomadas de un
asteroide que estaba distante en medio
del espacio y así llegamos al final de
las noticias aquí en france 24 más
información la encuentran en la página
web de france 24 punto com también por
supuesto en las redes sociales y en la
app descargando la en su dispositivo
móvil siga con nuestra programación
en las noches
[Música]